what's going on guys welcome to the
third ATR video and in the last video we
actually calculated ATR in this video we
want to go ahead and plot it up on that
chart if you don't have the chart and
you're not following this tutorial
linearly to get the chart that we're
going to edit into you're gonna want to
visit cent Dexcom slash starting point
dot pi pay attention to camel casing and
just do a nice control a control c and
then come over to a empty python script
and control V so here is our chart with
a nice blank start only to get your code
right here and this is where we're gonna
do it we basically want to take our
other script here the one we just wrote
go ahead and just remove this function
so we don't need it in this one and then
highlight here go all the way up to the
definition of TR copy that bad boy come
over here paste that bad boy right in
there you can scroll up here
and just up to here and tab tab to tabs
and everything will be aligned you guys
right now the next thing that we want to
do is to be come down here you they
execute up lights what do we want to
plot one plot TR dates to make sure it
aligns with the rest of the data we're
gonna go ahead and do - SP : SP starts -
for staining starting point and it's
basically so all of our data lines up if
you want to learn more about that watch
the charting tutorial anyway a TR again
- SP : or you could read the code and
probably figure it out anyway I want to
plot that with as a white line next
we're going to do plot y label and the y
label we're going to use is gonna be a
TR and since we're using 14 it's going
to meet here 14 finally since our
background is black our tech can't be
black so color is gonna equal white it
should be it hopefully not many years
it's pretty common that we'll get in
there those
we got anyway so we run it stock to plot
let's go ahead and do this on nope no
error nice so we bring it over here and
just drag it on our screen cool so now
you can see we got a TR looks about the
same as the one that I showed you before
Forex on and obviously if you want to
change up a TR it's relatively simple to
do you know so we can make a five five
will rerun it let's do another stock
let's do a Tesla so run for Tesla here
that's an interesting one isn't it Tesla
oversold man are over over by you
serious I would never have thought that
that's crazy man just kidding Tesla was
always kind of crazy anyway so as you
can see here volatility as price was
going up it was just like oh okay
Tesla is crazy right and then the RSI is
like uh watch out anyway that's funny
man RSI has been screaming since like
this point man and you can almost see
it's gonna come down almost at that
point that's that's awesome anyway so
the idea of starting point again is just
so it line like all this data lines up
at the same spot so it's just kind of
nice so anyways that's your ATR pretty
interesting for volatility again you can
see it matching up with with volume here
so I really think we measure up volume
and and the ATR it's just it's really I
think I think it's pretty impressive how
well this matches up and again it's
using two different data sets besides
volume so you can do some pretty cool
stuff anyway that's gonna include the
ATR video series or a mini series within
our Python mathematics and stock
indicator series a next video will be
all about the directional movement
system which uses the ATR here and
actually does pretty cool stuff so stay
tuned for that video hopefully that
sounds interesting to you guys as always
thanks for watching
thanks for this
hoarding the subscriptions and it's all
mixed up